bang what's going on guys hope you guys
are really excited about this interview
i really enjoyed it i think you will as
well but before we get into that make
sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy
in an interest bearing account or you
can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more all right let's get in this episode
i hope you guys enjoy this one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got ian
here with me thank you so much for doing
this sir
thank you for having me for sure let's
just jump right into your background
uh kind of walk us through uh how you
started your career and then eventually
how you get to uh graycroft
so um i i have a funny story about this
i
when i was in college i went to mit and
i had this internship doing spot pricing
for electricity across the united states
it's a quant
project and i found out a lot of things
about spot price and electricity too
which would be a fun digression for
another time
and the following summer uh dlj which
investment bank that was bought by
credit suisse showed up on campus
and they were the last bank to show up
to interview
and i was turned turned down by goldman
and morgan stanley and everybody else
but the energy group showed up and they
said oh my god we found somebody who
knows how to do energy spot price
calculations
and so i i got a job in the energy group
at dlj as a summer intern and then when
i showed up
for my first day of work as a summer
intern at 277
park avenue they put me in tech banking
and i said why am i in tech banking i
thought i was on the energy team
they said you went to mit didn't you i
said i would still go to mit
i said well we're trying to compete
against this guy named frank quatron
and the more mit people we have on our
team the better our pitch decks look
so you're on you're on the tech team now
and
uh honest to god and so i was a tech
banker
and i spent my whole summer flying on
the delta shuttle
from new york up to boston and we were
pitching vcs all summer
on this was 2 000. so this is like hey
day
internet bubble and i quickly realized
that while tech banking was good
the better job were the people that we
were we were pitching uh
it was summer in boston and they were
you know sitting in their offices no
socks and uh and you know nantucket
shirts on
and listening to the vcs uh talk to them
about ideas
so i tried to get into the venture
business and there were two vc firms
that interviewed on campus
at mit battery ventures and boston
millennia partners
and i happened to get a job at boston
millennia partners when i was
21 years old through on campus
recruiting
so i got into the venture business and
that was
that was 20 years ago so i'm i'm 41 but
i've been in the venture capital
industry
my entire career with the exception of
two years in in business school
and so when you show up on day one what
was your
thought process for you like man this is
wild
are you like i'm a genius and i'm ready
to hit the ground running like
i i'd say you know i've had every job
in the venture capital business i've had
analyst associate senior associate
uh principal partner effectively
managing partner
um and you know i i was never short on
confidence when i was 21 but i didn't
know anything
admittedly and uh
the firm i was at did a little bit of
everything they were doing biotech
and life sciences companies and optical
switches
and enterprise software and
i think what i found that i was good at
because
it was funny even a couple years later
when i was
first meeting alan patrickoff and we
were setting up graycroft and he asked
for
for references i had ceo references from
when i was 21 and 22.
um they liked me and i liked them and i
found
that even when i was right out of
college
i was able to talk to these
entrepreneurs
and come up with interesting ideas about
ways to
grow their businesses faster or maybe i
understood their business
as well or we just connected and
i think that's a very important skill
and the second thing is i've always been
really curious
about why the world works the way it
works
and you know call me like an info junkie
but i'm
i'm up every night till two o'clock in
the morning
i have a research report that's what i
was reading last night
how rigged are stock markets evidence
from microsecond timestamps which is a
national bureau of economic research
article
this is this was from 2017.
and how rigged are they they're not um
but uh well at least not in the way that
this group thought they were rigged
but you know i read this last night and
i was so interested
in the time stamp delta between the sip
and the exchanges
like nobody cares about this except for
like five weird people but i happen to
be one of those five weird people so
you know when i meet an entrepreneur
that's in the trading space and we can
have a conversation about that they
think it's really fascinating and i'm
always probing them for more information
so i can
go a little bit deeper i love it
talk a little bit about graycroft and
kind of the strategy
the uh the structure of the firm and
kind of what the focus is for you are
yeah so um greycraft today is 50 people
and there are there are two businesses
inside of graycraft we have an early
stage venture capital business
that is on fund six and
in total across all of those funds were
about
1.2 billion of lp commitments
um the in the second business is we have
a
a growth business venture growth
business and that's on fund
three and i believe are about 900
million
850 million dollars of lp commitments in
the
in the venture growth business uh as a
firm there are six areas
that we're currently focused on uh they
are
um on the enterprise side of the house
uh fintech and ensure tech so b2b
fintech insuretech
that's one area uh enterprise
application software
and enterprise infrastructure software
that's our largely our entire enterprise
side of the house and we've got 15
investment professionals roughly focused
on on those specific sectors
and then on the consumer side digital
health
consumer fintech and insure tech and
then consumer internet
and there's roughly another 15
investment professionals focused on
on the consumer side and this is
universal across both early stage and
growth just
the the difference is the stage of the
company
and it hasn't always been those sectors
by the way like we've
we've done all sorts of things over time
we were back in 2006 and 2007 doing
advertising uh technology companies and
we were doing a lot more media investing
we've subsequently moved to be got more
i guess traditional consumer internet
and um
and enterprise software so when you
think about kind of
switching focuses or switching sectors
what's the evaluation or framework
process that
you guys kind of think through to say
hey you know maybe we're not going to
focus as much on
sector a as we have been and sector b
now is somewhere where we're going to go
put our focus on
uh first is success begets success
[Music]
and um
we see things outside of those six
sectors and we're gonna do
and we still do it five or ten percent
of our
capital is deployed in opportunistic
areas
like autonomous transportation and
energy businesses and stuff that we
think are really interesting that
partner has passion for
oftentimes also it's an entrepreneur
that we've known for a really long time
that they'll start their second or third
business that we could even funded their
first or second business
and they go you know why don't you come
into my new company and say well we
don't
you know we don't have expertise in
vertical takeoff and landing autonomous
vehicles
i think well doesn't matter like we know
you you know us we didn't either we
figured it out over the course of the
last two or three years
and then through that investment we can
learn a lot
and uh i i think the
the venture business like all technology
you have to keep innovating
otherwise you die so when we come into
one of these spaces
it's the same questions like you know
what's the capital intensity of the
model
how long does it take uh to get product
market fit
how good is the team if you're
successful how big can it be
how do we underwrite it and um
i don't know i think when we started in
the media space
i think our the markets we started were
actually a lot smaller than the markets
we're in now
and part of the benefit of being in
financial services
and insurance the upside's a lot bigger
a lot more public companies in those
spaces
you've got this idea of kind of vcs uh
firms as platforms so we've seen this
with private equity firms obviously in
terms of
uh their ability to build out large
businesses
that really can do many different things
so for the companies that
uh they go ahead and they buy equity and
whether it's a majority or minority
stake
it seems like more and more venture
capital firms are starting to do that
uh as well just kind of walk me through
how you see that part of the business
evolving and then how you at graycroft
have decided to uh to kind of
perform you know services outside of
just pure investing
the the next phase of the venture
business is going to look a lot like
private equity or hedge funds and
we're in a talent game and it's the same
talent game
that every business is in and in order
to win at that talent game and this is
it's external talent so to building the
best companies we can
with the best entrepreneurs and the best
executives
that's an expensive endeavor in 2021
because
talent is is getting more expensive
every passing year
and then it's an internal talent game
where the
associates that we're trying to hire are
being cross rushed by d e shaw
and uh and apollo
and so um you can
you can get people who are more
entrepreneurial when you're smaller
to to leave jobs where they're making
a lot more money to come in and have
more responsibility in a bigger role but
i i think to really win in the venture
business and to have a world-class team
you've got to be able to pay people
fair salaries and what at least what
they could earn elsewhere
and so you need to be a bigger platform
to do that
um it's very hard we started a 75
million dollar fund
at graycroft i was probably the poorest
person
in my business school class uh for a
long
time uh because i'd made the decision to
work with my partners allen and dana
and there there's not a lot to go around
when you're managing 75 million bucks
with
office in new york an office in la
travel expense
overhead marketing it just it was really
hard
um and so
uh that's one piece and the second piece
is that
you know just the criteria the the back
office
and investment in data and technology to
be competitive
now is so much higher than it was even
15 years ago
we spend a million dollars a year in
data
when you say data explain like what
exactly that entails because i think
this is a part of
venture capital firms that maybe some
people don't know exist or don't
understand
um um well we're not talking like market
data right we're not buying
data feeds from the nasdaq or anything
um
we're buying exhaust data um
app performance data from app annie
consumer panel data from earnest we
happen to also invest in these companies
so
we find them like well if it's good
enough for us to buy from it should also
be good enough for us to invest in
um you know there's deep and dark web
data
there's all sorts of really interesting
information out there
um and then on top of that there's kind
of status quo stuff like pitch book
or um capital iq and you know
figuring out comps and
i i think that part of this part of this
data access
in the private markets in particular
because in the public market
uh the the companies themselves
published their
their results and you can append to that
some information from consumer panels to
see
you know as mcdonald's going to hit or
miss their earnings projection
and and that's a game that's being
played by hedge funds in the private
market no one really
knows how everybody's doing so you've
gotta you gotta figure out ways to
triangulate that
and and we spent a lot of time figuring
that out too because there's part of our
business that's
you know you gotta know if you're going
to be playing global fintech
like who are the who are the 10 best
companies in the world and how do we
make sure we don't get scooped on them
yep that that makes a ton of sense i
want to talk a little bit about
uh to the investments that you guys have
made that are in the portfolio but use
them as
uh kind of starting points for uh
conversation around the larger trends
and so maybe we will start with uh with
kind of the payment or fintech type
company
uh venmo and so obviously there's a ton
of innovation happening in
uh digital payments uh there's a ton of
uh kind of
experimentation happening especially in
bitcoin in the crypto markets
uh but also there's lots of uh that same
innovation
and progress being made not in kind of
blockchain or crypto enabled
uh products as well and so just how do
you look at that market what are you
excited about what are you not excited
about
and kind of what have you guys done
there
so we invested in the seed round of
venmo
in i think 2011
um might have been 2010 it was a long
time ago
and it was really interesting they came
into our office igram and cortina
and um they were
totally unregulated and uh and operating
in a gray area uh
and i believe all of the users were
friends
of ikram and cortina at the time they
had thousands of friends
who lived in uh hell's kitchen
um so so we looked at this and and i
called people and everybody said you'd
be crazy to invest in this company venmo
that would call paypal and we're
friendly with dan shulman
and dan wasn't there yet dan was still
at american express we called him too
and uh and they're like oh yeah you know
we do this already
but you'd go and you'd look at the
experience
of paypal 10 years ago where you got go
to a pc and log in or apple log in and
then send money over
and they're mobile apps for total
garbage and there's kind of mobile web
interface
and our view was that mobile was this
great unlock
um because i could pay people like i
don't need a wallet anymore just move
money around on my phone
and it's so much easier
and so they they developed that we
seeded them
along with excel
[Music]
and um you know the company grew very
fast
but they were losing money on every
transactions they were paying the
interchange fees for
credit and debit loading into the app
and they were losing so much money we
had to sell the company
so we sold them to braintree and then we
later invested in braintree and then
venmo consumed
all of the free cash flow of braintree
and was dragging them down
and then we had to sell that business to
um well ebay which owned paypal at the
time
and i think in hindsight we did okay we
i think a total we made
uh three times on our money um we could
have made
300 times uh you know the opportunity
was there
we later started a company called verse
which was the venmo of europe based in
barcelona
and they were acquired a year ago by uh
by square so it's now square cash's
product
and interestingly you know we had the
same
michael vaughn who was the ceo at venmo
and had spent 10 years working inside of
paypal was on the board of verse
and we got an acquisition offer from
from square and we called
we called paypal like well uh
we have an acquisition offer i can't
tell you who it's from but
you know we may be interesting to you
because you don't have a mobile app
in in europe and the paypal europe guy
said
mobile apps won't work for peer-to-peer
it was the same story
10 years later like you must be kidding
me
but you know there's really deep
entrenched not invented here
bias that happens in a lot of companies
so
like that's either be no if if venmo had
executed
on the right strategy there'd be no
chime
there there would be no square cash they
had such a huge head start for a decade
you know with all of those users hitting
what is fundamentally
a banking app but they didn't execute on
it and now
thankfully there's a million fintechs
that you know are all exciting consumer
businesses
um so that's kind of a long story of
of the peer-to-peer space the challenge
is you don't make any money
like these peer-to-peer hooks are really
good for customer acquisition
they're really hard to make money on so
it takes
hundreds of millions of dollars to scale
one of them to the point that you can
start capturing interchange or pay
people for instant deposit
and i think venmo finally turned a
profit last year for the first time
after over a decade of losses
when you look at um kind of the way that
that business
uh evolved over time and eventually uh
got
bought what do you think would have been
the things that they could have done
differently to actually go and capture
the opportunity was it
a lack of appetite was it like a
strategic
um omission or a mistake was it uh just
a different time and people you know
hindsight bias is kind of 2020
what do you think could have gone
differently in order for venmo to say be
an independent company
instead of acquired by paypal
uh that was a that was ten years of
tension that just got released right
there yeah it was
um i thought about that
i i don't know that anybody given the
the circumstances and the time period
and keep in mind
facebook was building facebook cash
and they were threatening us and square
was around and they were they were
eventually going to launch something
here because
jack dorsey is an amazing entrepreneur
and he was going to come into the
consumer space this way
so our founders at venmo
were first-time founders and they were
very young
and i don't think that people believed
and um when we the bigger question
because we were when combined with
braintree we were a very
formidable business uh at the time we
sold for 800 million dollars we were
many multiples the size
of stripe plus we had the payment
business that was growing really fast
and that goes down as one of the the
biggest regrets of my career
is we sold that business for 800 million
we had an
offer to raise a hundred from a
leaf excel at tiger and the board
decided to sell
and um and
we should have held i mean
for for many reasons we should have
helped with that that company would have
been worth
50 billion dollars even today and
braintree people don't talk about
braintree it's
it's still bigger than stripe
really yeah
[Music]
based on what measurement right payment
volume
and revenue and when you think of the
payment volume
where exactly is that coming from
because i definitely don't think people
uh think of that right whether it's just
they think stripe is so big and this
goliath or
uh they just aren't aware of braintree
where's that volume coming from well
the the us economy is really big and
you know if you if you handle the
payment
gateway for for big
enterprises and this is what
this is the motion in many of our
companies
you know they start off on stripe
because stripe has won
the minds and hearts of the developer
community
and at some point stripe becomes uh
inadequate because it they don't service
enterprise accounts particularly well
and it's also expensive
so you're paying for an obfuscation
layer on top of i believe stripe is
written on top of chase's core
i'm not sure but you know they they
don't have their own core there's
somebody else underneath
and you're paying for ease of use and
and apis and compliance and a bunch of
other stuff
um so you migrate
off to save a ton of money
and to get a more robust feature set and
um and braintree was so
early in the app store that i don't know
if they still have these accounts but
they were the payment gateway for uber
and the payment gateway for airbnb and
the payment gateway for everybody
uh they kind of owned mobile apps
and that was really really valuable
oceanfront real estate that um
just exploded in value
and it's once you're integrated with
them and they were more of an enterprise
player
and they're positioned as such so they
the accounts were very sticky
got it and even more so now that they've
got paypal
behind them because paypal's payment
services are
expansive yeah before we move on to the
next
uh kind of vertical is there any
opportunities in
payments or kind of these
consumer-facing uh fintechs
that you're like man somebody should go
build in the x
you know vertical uh or specific types
of companies you're looking for in case
anyone's building those companies they
can reach out
i'd say the the first thing we followed
was kind of the global proliferation so
like i mentioned we did verse which is
venmo in europe we did
eco which is the square of china and we
did flutter wave
which is kind of the braintree stripe or
alibaba for africa
um we should have done um toss
in south korea i spent a bunch of time
looking at it
and and we probably should have done um
paytm
in india but you're like there these
trends were kind of obvious
they had all started in the us and then
they went everywhere
um i'd say second uh
in terms of u.s innovation in consumer
fintech
you know there's a lot happening right
now in
um in the insurance space
and there's still interesting
opportunities there with embedded
insurance
that haven't been played out all the way
um
spending a lot of time on that
personally
uh you know i don't know that the
um the new mobile banking apps have seen
the end yet there may be somebody that
comes in over the top with something
really interesting um
i think that the annuities market like
if we really want to go into
interesting niches of financial services
i've spent the past year looking for an
annuities play
i've yet to find it and i've met with
dozens
i think annuities is so fascinating and
you know there aren't there aren't
really pensions
anymore so you get like these defined
contribution plans and what people
just want is assurance in their old age
that they're going to have money
and there's a lack of trust that the
federal government is going to be there
for you because
you know social security one minute is
underfunded by like a gazillion dollars
and the next minute it's not
no one really knows so um
if you could buy an insurance contract
that
pays you you know for the rest of your
life
enough that you don't have to worry
anymore i think a lot of people would
buy that the problem is annuities today
are rip off because the fees are so high
so you've got to figure out
how to get distribution right and the
underwriting right so they're not
paying you double to get your own money
back
so when you think through the annuities
and you say you talked to a bunch of
teams is that
teams that are working on the annuity
space and
you just are not convinced that's the
right team or the right strategy
or you've talked to a bunch of people
you know working in kind of fintech but
no one working on the exact
uh kind of point of the market of
annuities so we we've looked at
um specifically a few people
who have started companies in the
annuities market
and some of them are b to b to c
so they're building platforms for rias
or uh wealth management people
to distribute annuities and then there's
others that have taken an approach
that's more like acorns
with one of our portfolio companies but
it's like
instead of a passive savings app it's
savings and distribution
and it's geared towards an older
audience
and i i think the question for us is
we're going to
probably wait and see until somebody has
some interesting traction
or a really compelling team with a
repeat entrepreneur that we can back
um those would be kind of the two
criteria and once we find it we'll jump
on it
got it another area um is what i'll call
kind of consumer-facing brokerage
uh combined with uh kind of social
networking if you will right and so
obviously uh there's been a bunch of
talk about uh consumer
facing brokerage businesses you guys are
an investor in public.com
which is a variation or nuance of that
talk a little bit about that business
and then kind of that market
[Music]
so um the public was such a good story
because they the company um
was kind of started in our office at
graycroft
we we were pitched an idea on you know
what if venmo
and e-trade and this was before robin
hood was robin
but what what if venmo and he trade had
a baby
and the secret sauce of venmo
aside from the fact that they built a
good mobile app was the feed
right so if people would log in to see
what their friends were doing
and not even making payments just like
fear of missing out and that
was what tipped venmo over the
k factor one it wasn't like i'd send you
money and you have to go download the
app to get it's like that extra log
in every month where you're just sitting
at home wondering
like what your ex-girlfriend is up to
and you're like i wonder if she paid
anybody
and um similarly
you know we're thinking about the stock
exchange and saying well this is kind of
a an empty room problem because if you
don't know what to buy
and you don't have any real stock ideas
and there's nobody to follow like how do
you get
information around where to trade and
what to do and it's kind of a
single-player experience today going
into e-trade
so what if we could build a multi-player
experience
and um and yannick who's the is the ceo
and co-founder of the company
was introduced to me by a friend and
uh i was talking to yannick about like
what do you want to do next
and i realized that he was a really
talented designer
and i had friends with this kind of
brokerage concept like what if
uh what if venmo and e-trade had a baby
i said well yeah why don't we put you
together
and we can kind of build this and i'll
put some seed capital in if you'll agree
to join the company
so uh we made the intro and
you know the two sides hit it off and
the brokerage people liked yannick and
he liked the brokerage guys
and we funded the seed round and
um and the product was out of the gate
really kind of elegant
because yannick had a whole he he's
amazing
on ui and user interface and then he
recruited
uh his friend life abraham in new york
and they they met at precursor
so the two of them became co-ceos teamed
up and then we've been off to the races
and sure enough like the the investment
thesis
behind public was you couldn't beat
robin hood playing the same game robin
hood was gonna play
which is you spend hundreds of dollars
acquiring users on facebook
that that wasn't gonna be a sustainable
long-term differentiate strategy so you
had to build something that was social
that had an advantage cost of customer
acquisition
and it's hard to build social
applications
i mean there are very few successes in
the world but when you get it
right they really really scale because
they go viral and your acquisition costs
are lower and what we've seen in the
past
and year and a half is that play out
like i i would hazard to guess that our
customer acquisition cost
is one-tenth what robinhood's customer
acquisition cost is
so when you think through that um the
act the like actual acquisition cost
being lower is one
advantage are there other advantages to
having the kind of
you know social component or
conversation that you think about in
terms of
retention or something i've become more
interested in which is maybe
the type of buying behavior right so
incentivizing whether it's
more day trading more long-term
investing somewhere in between
uh and any kind of insights into like
the other
benefits to those features
uh i think that people there's more
trust
and i i don't know how to quantify that
but and it's still early days right
i mean we're talking
million users-ish platform we're not
talking bill you know
100 million yet so we'll see how it how
it is when it really scales
but um you know the uh
the trust is a big deal because when you
come into a platform and you see people
you know and i'm i get
texts from from my friends on public now
it's become kind of the
i don't know the fourth network um you
know instagram and facebook and that
universe
and twitter and that universe more
recently clubhouse
and what's going on in clubhouse and now
i've got my
finance feed which is really where
i think for most people most of their
net worth that in their house
it's going to be in stocks and bonds and
for retail investor having a feed around
that information
um is going to be really important for
one trust two idea generation and three
engagement
and what we do see we have a lot more
engaged users
because they're commun they're using it
to communicate in addition to trade
we've got an advantage customer
acquisition cost we're getting people
who come in and fund
relatively instantly and then they they
build an interesting and expansive
portfolio because they're following
people and getting ideas from from other
people on the platform
um you know i i think that
specifics about like what you trade and
what you buy is going to be finding your
own
tribe inside of this platform and people
are going to
follow the people they want to follow
and
i think ultimately there will be
gamestop users in one corner and
there'll be
people who buy berkshire hathaway in the
other corner and never look at it
um and that's fine
when you think about uh kind of this
type of
product uh is it a winner take all in
the sense of
maybe not on a market sense but you as
the user you're only going to use
one uh or is this going to be something
where you'll
be across you know multiple products and
and so having the differentiation
can actually be pretty important in
terms if you're not so much competing
just
on a binary basis do i get the user do i
not maybe actually what you're doing is
you're kind of competing for
uh you know mental share or or time
share
of that actual user um
it's it's going to be the latter not
winner take all it's going to be
you know you're going to have different
accounts for different things
um there's
a couple interesting one interesting
kind of non-public data point
so you know with with plaid
and i forget the name of the company
they bought but they bought a kind of a
brokerage login service at plaid
so you can authenticate your plat
account to services like atom finance or
toggle
and you can get portfolio analytics and
alerts
of my portfolio up down either news
um insights around technical measures
that are happening in my portfolio
we happen to have invested in both of
those companies by the way and the flip
the feedback we get
is well you know we've got a hundred
thousand authenticated users from robin
hood
but they've also authenticated their
other accounts
i said oh that's interesting how big are
the robinhood accounts and
where are they what's the cross section
where else or what else do robin hood
users have accounts
most robin hood users happen to have two
and a half other accounts
and those other accounts are a lot
bigger
so you know you'd like from a market
share perspective
there's two things that have happened
robin hood has become kind of a play
account
for a handful of people and they'll have
fidelity or t
row or whatever for another account
and the second piece is we also look at
kind of new entrants into the trading
market
and what is your market share of new
brokerage accounts created annually in
the us for first-time customers
and for a while robinhood was over 50
of those of those new accounts and it
looked like they were gonna
become more of a winner take all player
because if you're like if you're growing
faster than the market and you're
you're acquiring half of all new
brokerage accounts in the us you're
doing a great job
and in just the past
kind of couple weeks that's been
changing
and i think we'll see uh because the
market structure isn't final yet
and every day there's new people who are
either aging in
or coming into the market and um
you know i think you've seen with other
platforms that if you can build
something that's really social
it can be quite durable in these
competitive markets
so when you look at this um what's very
fascinating to me um is
you very quickly pointed out the annuity
business and payments
uh it seems like from the surface
everyone has tried
everything in brokerage uh do you
evaluate it the same way or are there
things that you say nope
we're looking for you know kind of x
variation or
x kind of application when it comes to
brokerage
everybody's not tried everything yet in
brokerage
i figured that was going to be your
answer yeah um
there are a lot of good ideas that
haven't been tested yet
i i don't i don't want to leak the
public 2021
roadmap on a public okay but there's a
lot of good stuff coming
okay are there things that uh maybe are
other
parts of the brokerage uh market that
you know kind of are outside of
what public would go after that you're
looking for
uh and really just if there's a founder
working on something that
uh could be a potential fit they can
reach out
um like i think ultimately if they
you think about this as a retail
investor wealth management platform
and there will be at some point crypto
and
alts and we're also in yield street
right which is the other side of the alt
universe and it's so interesting like
you should have
today probably three or four different i
mean
if you're an accredited investor if
you're not a credit investor if you're
uh various levels you could you should
probably have a couple different
accounts
and i'm curious to see if public or
yield street
kind of get closer together over time or
if they go into even more esoteric
unique verticals to just kind of one's
going to own alts and one's going to own
public equities and crypto kind of sits
in between in a bit
because you'll have crypto lending as a
a high-yield
asset class perhaps in the future on a
yield streak but you'll have the actual
crypto assets
on on a public brokerage
got it that uh that makes a lot of sense
uh before we wrap up i always
ask everyone the same three questions uh
and you'll get to ask me one to finish
up the first is just what is the most
important book that you've ever read
and i'll expand it a little bit for you
because it sounds like you read all
kinds of different data points all sorts
of reports so maybe
it doesn't have to be just a book but
just the most important piece of content
that you've consumed
you know i i love science fiction
and this is probably the not
a great answer but um
i like the isaac asimov foundation
series
i loved that um yeah it also depends
like i read that at an age where
it i it had quite an impression on me
too
and one of the interesting takeaways
from from that series is that the
technology you build to sustain yourself
and in in his world there was like uh
there was a a universe of people who
built things that were really big and
expansive and another universal people
built things that were
very small and you they think about
the united states and the way our
country has evolved and they were like
these
really big projects like the hoover dam
and the highway system
and there was a time in our country's
past
when people had those types of big
projects and then for a really long time
it was
you know microchips and nanotech
and biology and you know things that
were very small i i kind of like well
that's really interesting around how in
1951
a science fiction author could kind of
dream ahead
about the way that society would evolve
that way
and i was i thought it was really
fascinating i don't know that's
necessarily the most important book but
i thought it was really an interesting
book um
but i say it's not the best answer but
that that
that's uh it's okay it's the one that is
impactful
right which i think is uh is one element
of importance for sure
uh the second question is uh from our
friends over at eight sleep
uh i've been sleeping on their
thermoregulated bed for a while now
uh make it ice cold and sleeping a
little baby and so i've become a
convert of the sleep religion when in
the past i was not
uh what's your sleep routine do you
sleep uh
five or six hours are you more like
eight nine hours
and how's that evolved over time um
so i am a in probably a seven to eight
hour a night post coveted sleeper
and i say it's very specific because
really since we went work from home in
march my sleep has been amazing
before then because i i live just
outside of the city
in um in larchmont it was
it was like oh god another hour to get
home and then you're trying to find
time so i probably sleeping like six or
seven hours
and there's a life-changing difference
to get an extra two hours a night of
sleep
um yeah
two hours of sleep if you had told me uh
a year and a half ago
i would have been like ah that's like
what's two hours now
uh 30 minutes can be uh could be pretty
impactful let alone two hours
yeah i've got two little kids too so
sleep is precious around here
i hear you uh the last question is a
little bit more fun
uh aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
and and this is like aliens like
you want to define weaver things coming
out of your chest
or this is like somewhere in this whole
universe there are going to be other
intelligent life forms
because however you want to define it
i'd say i believe
that somewhere in the universe there are
other intelligent
life forms yeah i i don't know that i
will live to see any of them and i
i highly doubt that i will but i just
believe they're out there
so i'm uh i'm in the same boat uh i
guess that leads the question then of do
you
want to live long enough to
meet them well i want to live that i
want to live forever but i don't know
what's going to happen
maybe my maybe my conscience will be
uploaded into the cloud
and virtual ian will meet them in the
year 2 500.
that's a good way to look at it you
could ask me one question
to uh to finish up what one question do
you have for me
um who's the who's the favorite
interviewer you've had on your show uh
i don't have one i mean come on come on
now okay which one of your two kids is
your favorite
right like depends on what what day it
is
i'll ask you a separate question uh
i'll ask you but what's the most
interesting question anyone's asked you
and you gave them the chance to ask you
a question
um there's been a lot of uh
people actually really bad asking
questions as i'm sure you have
figured out as you talked to so many
people yeah i
[Music]
there know um there's two types of of
people who ask bad questions there's the
just lazy like
kind of you know what's the thing that
would be the most obvious thing to ask
uh and then there's uh the second group
which is
uh they ask questions that uh
don't really have a a purpose or like a
um
a conversation thread and so sometimes
uh people will ask me you know
uh what's gonna happen to bitcoin or
like you know something like that it's
like uh
i have no clue but by far the best ones
uh are always the more philosophical
questions i think that
uh make me critically think about like
why something right so it's it's less
about like what's gonna happen to
bitcoin it may be like
why do you think it was created or why
do you do what you do on a daily basis
or you know you said x why do you
believe that
and i think that um it goes back towards
it like that toyota you know ask
why five times um i i think is a
a really kind of um timeless principle
and so just people who kind of
pull at that uh is
let me ask you a question i've got a
better one okay
um when we looked at
like sports betting sites and
etoro back in the day when they were
doing only forex
and and even the very first round
of robin hood it it
when i when you look at their revenue
all of those
companies have revenue that is directly
correlated to their customers losses
the more their customers lose the more
money they make
and i looked at that and i said i have a
moral problem with that
and i was on an island inside of
graycroft
advocating like guys like do we really
want to be investing
in things that entice people to do
financial actions or bets with whatever
it is that
that the owners of the properties
themselves know
are not in their customers best interest
and i know you've interviewed a lot of
people
who are in this world who run sports
betting sites
who've been involved in you know forex
trading platforms and new retail
brokerage stuff
like do you have what's your take
on the moral authority of the media
and is it buyer beware in your world or
do you feel like you've got a
responsibility to people
to let them know at the end of the day
that you know day trading is going to
result in losses
and what's your view
yeah so i think there's uh kind of
different elements
to this based on which market
participant we're talking about right so
like
the requirement or or the expectation of
the media is different than the
platform owner that's different than
just a commentator versus a
trader if you will right and i think
that let's just focus
just on the companies themselves uh i do
think that there is
a much more sustainability like it's
actually better for business to align
yourself with your customer
right so sure you can make money with uh
if it's something where your customers
are losing money but
ultimately like they don't want to lose
money so they're likely to go somewhere
else
especially if somebody can build a
better model the second thing that i
think is
um you know kind of left out of the
conversation
is uh there's almost variations to if
you do have a business model where
it is predicated on uh your customers
losing money
um just explicitly stating that right
like like i think the
part where it gets really bad is when
you start to compound issues so it's
like okay one you've got a business
model that is
uh antithetical to what your customers
trying to achieve then on top of that
you don't tell them
and then on top of that like then you
you know make it even easier for them to
lose money or what you know it's like
you start to stack stuff on top and it
just increases
the the odds that you win they lose
uh and so i think forgetting finance
just in general i think the most
sustainable business models are
where you help your customer achieve
their goal
and figure out how to make money around
that um you know finance is this weird
thing where the entire industry almost
feels like
uh people are very uh kind of zero-sum
right you know in markets etc but i
think that that's changing right
i think that companies are starting to
wake up to the fact like hey if i want a
sustainable business
probably should figure out how to do
this in a way that uh that doesn't screw
over the customer
yeah we we've been working at great
growth really hard on that
it's not easy and it's a story that
doesn't get a lot of press
but avoiding platforms that trade
against your users for instance
and uh in crypto there's even exchanges
that will take the other side of trades
so that's surprising right
um all right yeah listen thank you so
much for your time this is fantastic
uh you're incredibly thoughtful uh and
the track record speaks for itself where
can we send people to find you on the
internet or find out more about what a
great craft is working on so uh
our website graycroft.com you can follow
me on twitter
it's my last name sigaloa and um
if you need to reach me my email is ian
at graycroft
awesome man listen thank you so much for
uh for your time and we'll have to do
this again in the future
thanks take care